this is Startalk this is Startalk
and I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist I work at
the American Museum of Natural History
in New York City where I serve as
director of the Hayden Planetarium and
today I have with me my coach Chuck nice
that's right hey nail Chuck good to be
you're always good to have you always my
pleasure and you're wearing your
official NASA uniform that's without a
doubt you know I figured this was
appropriate attire for what we are doing
you know that and it's the only clean
thank you making that clear so this is a
this is a cosmic queries edition a star
talk as it is and in this cosmic queries
we're going to be talking about the
science of war yeah man ooh
science of humans at war yeah and I have
to tell you man people are obsessed with
the subject I I don't understand how
that I don't know I don't get it I have
never received the breath of queries
because you solicited questions on this
topic already yes we have okay so the
questions from all over again I was told
this morning that this would be the
topic but you've been scheming yeah all
week on the week long we've been
receiving questions and I have to tell
you that people are very passionate
about it and they're uh you know they're
doing a lot of deep thinking you know
okay a lot of questions I'm like you
were clearly high would you like that
question right you had to be sad to
write that question because that's
because I because I don't have any walls
you don't get to see the questions
what's that's true but though I'd be a
scientist I have no particular expertise
in this topic right okay so I figured
okay then they plunked a book down in
front of me called grunt the curious
science of humans at war so I said damn
I got to read this book like in the next
hour but then they told me no Mary wrote
the author of the book and here with us
from Oakland California Mary Rose yes
thank you Mary does not your first time
on Startalk no now's like your fourth
time or something I think we yeah
therefore yeah you got like the coolest
start talking in books we could ever
find so great great to have you
in here so basically these questions are
going to be for Mary yeah for them I'll
be Mary sidecar on right I could back
her up with some physics if we need it
right this is her book for the most part
this is this is what people are Mary I'm
not gonna lie to you and say oh I read
this book and I haven't read it yet I
just saw it like this man I jump on
every other talk show host is lying to
you when they said they read your book I
know you know that I know I haven't read
it either
I don't remember what's in it I wrote it
a long time ago
okay we'll see what they will see what
the people say like I said some of the
questions are out there which is before
you going okay it's just an overview
yeah what is this subject okay so this
is military science but specifically not
the weapons and the bombs and the right
strategy which I'd from you may have a
lot of questions there about that when I
will turn those all over to you okay so
this is the human right yeah is it
extreme heat and loud noises right here
and panic and flies and diary and all of
the things that people don't necessarily
think about but the military thinks
about because it knocks soldiers out of
commission and anyway so yeah that kind
of let's it's all in here so this is
like your this was your next project
after all these other completely
far-flung places you have been in your
book portfolio yeah you think I would
take a body of knowledge that I've
worked on and build upon that so that I
don't know start all over again
Arco knowing nothing right listen I this
okay yeah we're still before okay what
is the most weirdest scientific thing
you can share with us about military
grunts okay here okay here's justice
just start the soil here first a book
starts out with the chicken gun and I
love the chicken gun because I like to
say the word chicken whenever possible
right chicken guys I think I know the
chicken gun story do you yeah yeah I
have never out of the gambino your what
the chicken case you're testing the the
the the canopy airplanes quieter pilots
okay right so okay the chicken is a
stand-in for your turkey vulture your
Canada goose your Starling whatever it
is it's kind of a worst-case scenario to
change it's a kind of odd choice because
it doesn't chicken doesn't actually I'm
not going to no matter how long your
pilot you are never going to actually if
it's a bird and it's readily variable at
your grocers it's because
Christian right yeah so you take it
frozen chicken you thaw it out you load
the chicken gun and you fire it at the
canopy right yes at the same speed that
the plane would otherwise encounter it
flying into the air right but it was
there were a lot of thought went into
this because there's also because I
don't Valley well I the chicken this
will be it's very dense it's a big heavy
thing that'll be great blood in fact
there's something called pause for drama
the feathered bullet phenomenon will be
feathered bullets phenomena
tiny little bird Leo Starling maybe it's
the way to appear just like a bullet
right into the pilot so actually yeah so
you know do you think you haven't
figured out yet we'll use a chicken and
then there's and then all of a sudden
bird comes through and shoot you in the
head well because the bird appears a
tinier hole and that yeah it's a
different kind of impact basically that
was not people more so it's closer to a
bull okay so to test this they should
just shoot bullets you can sit here
let's see right a bullet ready right or
find a Finch that's packing I have a
bird fire a gun right exactly just four
days ago I was at Edwards Air Force Base
and I saw the canopy of the f-22 fighter
and it was large and beautiful
it was completely transparent and what
the pilots were telling me is that now
it's not just a canopy to their side
into their front it is completely around
them and so they have full high-quality
visual confirmation of anything that's
around them right and I said shouldn't
you be flying with instruments rather
than relying in your own damn eyes yeah
that's normally the pilots way oh okay I
on instrument as I know if you're a
fighter pilots when I talk well but
anyway let's get to yeah yeah
interesting again
yeah but you got the cage on the bottom
I found out is it when birds birds and
planes take off into the wind so the
birds are like oh no no no head no law
they're not looking behind so they don't
have a visual awareness to get out of
the way so that was a that's a problem
not looking at what's coming at them
right the planes coming up from behind
for me that's one of the one of the most
beautiful metaphors do tell it's
in life mm-hmm here we go
when the wind is against you right
remember that is exactly the condition
to take planes take flight and that's a
bit that is a beautiful metaphor right
that mine is went away in any case I'm
sticking with the airplane here I ruin
my metaphor yeah so chicken more lovely
Canada goose yeah the plane wants to
high speed it can be relative to the air
it's not about the ground right about
the air so you take off into the moving
air then you can take off at a lower
ground speed because your air speed
higher that's all that's just going the
birds figured that out too yeah yeah
very intelligent so let's do this Chuck
you solicited questions on this topic
and we have them and our first question
is a patreon patrons question which of
course if you uh if you actually support
us on patreon then we will put your
question to the top of the queue and
that right resident yes as a matter of
fact actually buying their way to the
top of the thing I can think of no
better way to get people to participate
okay or to get votes
okay okay by the votes okay what's your
first question this is from Jeff prime
who is a patreon patron and Jeff wants
to know this from Omaha Nebraska my unit
and I were deployed in Iraq from 2007 to
2008 I personally have known several men
from my unit that suffer from PTSD while
other members do not with all our
variables being equal is there a
biological reason why some soldiers
handle war differently in a mental
capacity that helps explains why some
soldiers suffer PTSD while others do not
good one very very good deadline right
yes when I do not know the answer cool
yes okay I have it yeah they have it
moving on joking I can reflect on this
virus probably there's probably a reason
yeah I would think that if we knew that
definitively then we would be able to
delineate why that is and then look for
a cure to PTSD which are or keep those
people out of what one of the
things in the book was there looking at
heat injuries and there's a huge
individual variation and who can
acclimate to extreme heat like you can
feel like start sweating heavy and
sooner and is like you like I can deal
with this and other people can't and
they get heat stroke and they sometimes
die pretty high but in a wide range of
temperatures yeah what I found is oh
could you put on the heat if you put on
it and I'm just kind of antsy chillin
with the cool alright no I'm just are
self regulating yeah kinda it's not that
I don't feel hot or feel cold it's that
I'm okay with it
now you have a psychological you just
roll with everything it is psychological
rather than physiological I in either
case I still want to know who's
susceptible pedia to PTSD who isn't
right right of course there's that very
famous scene I know only know it from
the film I assume it was true with
Patton walks into a infirmary infirmary
yes and there's these wounded soldiers
they're bandaged and there's one elder
who has no wounds at all he's there in
tears at the edge of that what they call
back then shell shock shell shock and
then combat fatigue it was combat see
and now it's PTSD happiest did not what
it was enough syllables you gotta get
more real when you have more syllables
finally yeah so so he slapped he
bitch-slap yeah he did the soldier and
this made it to the press that he had no
sort of compassion compassion yeah I was
empathy for empathy for the yeah man he
was saying he didn't bother him
apparently so he figured everybody else
should I guess it was a day when
psychological injury was not viewed as
the same as physical injury
whereas today so often I this is how we
do okay yeah well she got that's a great
question
mister remains a great question without
an answer available as a stable you know
I don't have an answer there's nothing
wrong with that okay
now this one is really for Neil uh Mary
uh and I'm reading it meal because I'm
not sure what this guy's talking about
okay and this is from Nick sahs from ski
says from ski you think that's right so
it's Franz
right subs subs from the France key
that's right truck if you start
pronouncing names correctly then we
won't know to do with you however you
want and that's your thing that's my
thing I don't think the France key I
don't know so thank you right what uh
here we go Anna um this was I'm a young
sci-fi writer and fantasy I'm currently
working on a hard science fiction book
my question is how much do we understand
here's the thing meal exotic particles
what if any effect they do have on the
human body and and then he says if you
put a blurb about my book I really
appreciate yeah I don't think I'm gonna
do the blurb about the book but I think
I have a way to link this back to Mary
but we we have the portfolio of
particles that exist that I measured
that names if masses they have you know
energies in different states and this
sort of thing and half-lives and so some
particles just go straight through you
like neutrinos right billions go through
you every square centimeter every second
from the Sun and they do nothing to us
they don't interact what matters is if
they interact with you that's the
difference okay and if they interact
they could do damage and so so this is a
so if you want to weaponize a particle
you would make some kind of device that
you know contains particles that will
interact with your body in some way yes
with your DNA that's with your skin mess
with whatever and then that becomes a
weaponized Raygun basically so you make
the particles a delivery system for some
type of debilitation correct correct now
we do this for for electromagnetic
energy so there's a there's a movable
microwave device which is an it's a
non-lethal anti-personnel weapon that is
non-lethal so if there's a crowd of
people you drive up this truck you aim
this antenna at the people and it's like
you just put them all in a microwave
oven now do you first get them to hold a
burrito okay so they can eat it on the
way you got to take the wrapper off
so so what happens if their skin starts
feeling hot and they and they want to go
out of the beam so they scattered it
scattered they scatter so you can
decentralize what might be a mob that
that's that's coming is there any
discussion in the military about weapons
the effect of weapons on people that are
not just gun that your traditional well
there was not in this book of one of my
previous books there was infrasound I
mean which book this was even though
they were there was this so emotional
memory book that was in that she wrote
that's pretty cool yeah that's that
badass actually yeah yeah in some book
that I wrote so what you can all you all
do is like buy them all a mouse but I'd
like to it you let me know you buy them
all right so yeah in but infrasound
there was just talk about that there
that the military was looking for a
non-lethal weapon I think was it
supposedly it would know is infrasound
any of those like long slow way
frequency where frequency and that it
would have the same resonant frequency
as some of the internal organs so you it
would create fear nausea terror and yeah
never this is like in Jurassic or
anywhere t-rex
yeah like the liquid right and you see
the the vibration in the liquid in the
glass right right right
that type of deal yeah like they were
similar like they would launch a ball of
inference AAB there be t-rex would be
one of the settings right yeah yeah by
the way the military doesn't have to
look for that we already have it it's
called one direction yeah you're a boy
band well they were some concern about
NASA had concerns about because the
engines were put in a launch they would
be putting out tremendous amounts of
infrasound and they were afraid they're
going to deliver jelly to the moon that
they would even it was so that instead
but I think it turned out it wasn't but
in fact they do have what they call a
sound abatement system and before every
launch in two seconds before they ignite
the engine you see this basically a
swimming pools worth of water dumped on
launch pad and the water absorbs the
acoustic reverberations that's right
they're worried that the acoustic
reverberations would just completely
we tear apart entire bottom half for the
rocket I like the the singer with the
glass breaking shatter exactly yes
Annette so what they do is they put in
the water that absorbs the energy and
that way the energy doesn't hit the
rocket again so next time watch very
closely every single launch and their
big tanks yeah rounding launch pads
their water tanks
bada-bing and then the vibrations hit it
vaporizes the water so some of the smoke
you see coming out is is steam basically
it's authorized by the energy the
acoustic energy of vibration that's
amazing give me one more question by the
way that is the exact sound that it
makes when the water is dumped but a
being a big it's awesome it's awesome to
us Chuck okay here's here's a quick one
since we don't have a lot of time tech
advancement through Wars from Mattie
stark on facebook says this how do you
feel about the idea that war is
necessary for technological advancement
whoo
let me let me let me can't say it in a
grunt question okay okay so how much
have we how much has war advanced
medicine a lot in terms of combat trauma
to me did stuff like alright you get
somebody whose arteries cut and they've
got about two minutes so you know get it
in terms of getting what it did so they
bleed out and they're dead two minutes
to stable I get to stop the bleeding
stabilize them and get them somewhere
they've gotten really good at that
so emergency care that's been huge of
course the whole concept of triage a war
based yeah we're basically also things
you wouldn't necessarily think about
there was an Navy guy captain Phillips
not that other captain Phillips who K
came up with this discovery that if you
if so we've got extreme diarrhea like
cholera where you're like losing five
gallons of liquid you even invented this
thing the cholera caught it's a cot with
a hole in a bucket you're just your ear
you're going to die quickly because
you're just right ticking right you're
leaking so what does he invented the
bucket what's white that's not very well
the cholera [ __ ] was one event but not
the important one the important one was
if you add glucose to the rehydration
fluids it enhances absorption of the
fluids and the salt so now you can drink
them rather
hook up an IV so in a third-world
country where somebody they have to make
their way to a clinic and get hooked up
to an IV they can actually drink this
stuff and it's saved you know millions
of life cause it's still like to TM to
some million people died so here's
here's a more good question you ready
ready I'm always there have more people
have more lives been saved by the
medical advances from war than lives
that have been lost from the waging of
war itself Wow interesting well they
okay well here's a figure for you this
war is good for you people I now have to
kill you in order to save you let's go
let's go to commercial and we'll we'll
cogitate on that question when we come
back Startalk continues with our cosmic
queries edition with Mary Roach author
of grunt the curious science of humans
at war
we're back to Startalk Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your host and your personal
astrophysicist we're doing cosmic
queries love cosmic queries Chuck you're
helping me out here absolutely and you
solicited questions from the from now
our internet base as we have and using
they knew in advance before I knew even
with these cards you never get to see
that I don't get I don't you know what
even though we're not trying to stump
you that's not the not the point I get a
point here is not to give you a question
that you cannot answer but it's to think
that might be the point yeah babies more
fun there are some people yeah not for
me Oh Mary Roach is with us and her new
book just released this thing still
smells like it's got a new book smell
good format you can buy that spray it is
released and then its old book smell the
curious science of humans at war and and
I'd left you with a question just before
the end I just wanted to know given
given how many lives have been saved by
medical advances from innovations during
war could one make the case the morbid
case that the number of people who have
died at war is less than the number of
lives who have been saved by the medical
advances derived from it probably just
from the the dysentery and diarrhea
statistics alone I mean you're tiny okay
so 2.5 million people a year still there
wh oh that's the figure for death World
Health Organization held to this day yes
a million people died from dehydration
from diarrhea a lot of intolerant or
some other and yeah in developing
nations so that's a huge one half
million a year
absolutely India from from yeah exactly
okay so a 50 million people died in the
Second World War it was last number I
checked so 25 years of that that's just
the diarrhea alone right but but they
are dying we didn't stop them from dying
so I want to know if wives have been
saved
no but you saying that just the
advancements that we've made to combat
that may may have saved a significant
number of lives whether or not it
balances we don't know but I do my
statistic that you know those they're
still dying they're still dying out so
what you're saying that number could
have been much large much larger man
that's what number this ugly yes number
they're still dying it would have been
huge her huge huge it would have been
huge
just like my hair huge okay huge I may
not like my hands no you know what is
some recently saw statistic on the the
number of deaths from car crashes versus
in LA every year that there's been a
military conflict the number of deaths
just from car crashes Dwarfs the number
from killed in whatever the war that's
going on not not the second world war
but surely soon ya know since then we
lose we lose 100 110 attack now are they
only are they only accounting American
deaths or are they coming the number of
people because we tend to kill a lot
more people exactly yeah that's true
sure but I can tell you it's a hundred
people a day on the roads and at the
peak of the Vietnam War we were losing a
hundred servicemen a week so it's
basically a factor of seven higher out
in cars then in military not not the
First World War was about the Second
World War but here's something I'd
tweeted recently the Second World War
you do that you run the math we were
losing 1,000 humans per hour Wow 1000
per hour died at the hands of another
human being
during the six years of the Second World
War hmm wow that's a thing yes however
the mexican-american war seven to one
ratio disease to combat injury ooh
dysentery diarrhea malaria seven two to
one crystal you think Mexico and
diarrhea they're always going to be
linked Wow III know so Mexico even back
then retrovirus of water that event yeah
oh yeah there was that quote William
Osler dysentery has been more fatal to
soldiers than powder or shot well that's
even as good as your chicken metaphors
you let loose earlier not I've read all
right Chuck what else yeah here we go
let's move on hmm
this seems to be a big theme that people
want to know about and this is this is
from Aaron
harren filth okay that's the name that's
how you're pronouncing the name but go
on
no no Phi LT you have fun with how you
can't pronounce stuff okay all right go
on maybe just run
remember never wrote it would wrote it
that way to make this mess with me all
right here we go
hi Neil really love the show keep it up
my question is in recent films such as
Civil War we're talking about Marvel
Comics Civil War we see genetically
advanced soldiers like Bucky who's a
character at Captain America's friend
I'm sorry I'm translating as he asked a
question and the winter soldiers a also
part of the genetically modified
soldiers could super soldiers eventually
become a reality if so what are the
biological implications of doing such a
thing
greetings from Mexico City oh yes this
is the show for you
what's so merry go to Mexico City it's
supposed to be great so Mary are there
studies of have there been attempts to
modify the human physiology in war I saw
this amazing paper DARPA you know DARPA
Harper's the way outside the box Defense
Advanced Research Project - yes it was a
paper it was speculation it was not
projects that are underway but they were
listing like one of the poll points of
DARPA is to have highly speculative
research it could break open a whole new
field of military might okay this was in
particular modifications to the human
body what could we do and inspiration
from the animal kingdom so they were
looking at unis unis hemispheric sleep
which you have in marine mammals and in
some geese and noggin and what do you
want I'll try oh yeah exactly
so they funded some research with some
basic research into marine biologist and
bird people ornithologists would be the
I guess the way I call for people look
it's looking at people I go on bug
people yeah yeah but people have
probably been doing some work too but
yeah funny just looking into like how
does this work and said we foster this
and somehow make our soldiers able to
sleep emka sleep deprivation is huge and
it affects your performance your
military performance so there are a way
to sleep with one half
the brain and keep the other eye open to
make sure nobody's sneaking any swap
brain halves yeah presumably both halves
next time Yeah right yeah all right so
so was that it was an it was an amazing
list there were things like human llamas
or what could you oh gee you know
somehow had more hemoglobin for mountain
warfare could you make somebody able to
kind of Sherpa eyes them quickly to be
able to bring you into function better
high altitudes
I do remember surgically installed gills
was on the list whoa okay now yes
actually like Waterworld right there
what hey exactly what I was telling
Kostner know about this that's great
we're going to work on we're going to
try him out first when he came around
his neck and you saw the girls yeah yeah
so so here's my take on that not that
anybody asked but I'll tell you my take
at the early days of space exploration
there was all this talk about modifying
the human physiology to accommodate the
stress and strain on our body in space
and in almost every case they came up
with an engineering solution to the
problem rather than a biological one
we're therefore was not invasive to the
human body they would talk about is
there some pill you can take where the
brain would not require as much oxygen
when you do a high G turn out from a you
know from a as a fighter pilot might
when when they're turning around and
then in that way your brain wouldn't
need as much oxygen in still and then
the engineers just developed is the
suits right where they just means your
leg as you're like bloody got no way to
go right right so so so many of these
are injured how about one where you
don't feel nauseous and feel nausea in
zero-g or you can just spin up the space
station and create 1g so so my my oh you
you want to make bulletproof skin or
just make Kevlar bullet and wear a
bulletproof vest right so want the
bullet to skin sanim you're just I'm
just going to go on record and say the
bulletproof man is what I would go for
so I'm more Tony Stark on this give me
the give me the suit give me the power
the money and the brains and we'll make
we'll make anything we need I will be
able to fly
oh that's cool now what else again all
right um Johnny Glasgow from facebook
says hi Neil it would be Facebook our
followers on Facebook followers on
Facebook headquarters my face right
exactly right he's not actually having
coffee with Zuckerberg right now he says
hi Neil hi Mary what scientific advances
made during wartime have the biggest
positive effect on our civilian lives
today hmm
I'm going to have to go with the medical
stuff the medical stuff yeah the stuff
we were talking about earlier we're
talking about really bad that the most
positive affective effect yeah right
i'ma get you talked about maybe you like
taking forward the whole notion of
drones completely taking humans out of
the equation but that's you know it's
got other issues but the whole episode
on Star Trek hmm that was indeed they
fought the war through mathematical
calculations right and then people
report it to a chamber for dilation
because the calculation showed that you
would have been it would have been
killed in the in a bat walk in and they
took him out right exactly and that
which is that after curtain no you can't
do that way thank you yeah
is not more Oh ugly and bloody socks ed
actually note statistically I can see
the merit of lubricating or approach
well that's cool yet that so definitely
be the medical advancements is that's
what comes to mind in terms of a
positive yeah positive okay I would say
no irony just a logical event say one
thing I had the v2 rocket was the very
first intercontinental ballistic missile
which became the foundation of our
entire space arsenal ah everything that
we know and love about space including
where you get your your your your
weather maps from from the Weather
Channel
you get people out am i going to tell me
what do I need space for I have my GPS
in the Weather Channel that's all I need
yeah that's like get your intro
government hands off my Medicare that's
what that state is exactly look at it so
I would say I know
at yen acid I mean anything that's
miniaturized fire or yet the entire
miniature light weight that was NASA
more I know and it's by there's probably
more didn't have to miniaturize the way
NASA and I have to launch it for you
know well then I can cost you money it's
a war thing though the first ten
thousand dollars a pound to orbit yeah
so if you got a little extra cut yeah I
ain't flying that in right you ain't go
back on a treadmill yeah so how about
this I believe the first computers were
used to calculate the trajectory of
mortar shells and it's tennis is that
correct that is true okay yes yep yep
and now we have computer I mean we know
what they do now yeah yes so in fact the
military led the development of
supercomputing yes that's right right
nowadays it's commercially driven
because the demand is there but in their
in the day yeah back in the day right
there you go all right
all right well not bad not bad at all
okay what else oh yeah here we go
okay here we go
well you know what this is kind of the
same question so I'm going to skip that
I'm sorry um do vet of armed combat face
a dis purport I'm sorry Christian your
last name I tried to get away without
just but I'm going to try it here we go
this is from Christian prison black
prysby lick okay here you go Mary take a
look I'm just messing with you chuckling
hey just messing with it out Christian
right where the Joe Smith's out there
Facebook please laughs I know Joe Smith
I asked Chuck a question I know where's
Joe Smith when I need up okay Christian
prysby late from Twitter says this do
vets of armed combat face a
disproportionate number of chronic
health issues and does race play a role
or or as well as class so class and race
do they play a role in the chronic
health issues that vets face and do vets
face more chronic health issues than
anyone else by virtue of being a vet I
wouldn't yeah yeah yeah there's a
tremendous amount I mean he's like just
starting with here
the number-one VA expense hearing loss
really come away with EMEA it's not just
it is not just rifle and bombs going off
in rifle fire its steady-state noise a
year in a Blackhawk helicopter is like a
hundred and six decibels and hearing
person have hearing protection structure
material like that like that can you do
a m16 uh well m16 is a little bit more
staccato so is an m16 the rifle yeah
duck yeah I do but then there's a Huey
from Vietnam no it's like it was that it
was a it had a pulse it was a pulsing
pulsing sound she's saying consistent
about rate together assistant Lee being
persistently bathed in high decibel
sound even beyond just whether you would
near an explosion right and and the
other problem is that when the when the
noise assuming things go kinetic when
there's five for me and when there's
like there's no warning you have time to
literally roll down my phone mere plug
oh my oh you're back and put that you
know you there's just not time and
they're not going to wear that stuff all
the time cuz you lose your situational
awareness you can't hear somebody
shouting get down had somebody over
there so they they're trying to do that
in some movies well they have yeah they
have special operations is really cool
you bionic hearing it so called his
headset and it attenuates the loud
noises changes with do right so the loud
stuff gets quieter and the quiet stuff
is amplified so you're like the by on I
was like did it
I could hear across the room yeah that
was no that was the I what you're doing
was that the I was beyond oh that was a
year okay see you're right yeah you know
me summers heavy ears
she had the it actually selling
mattresses late-night-tv can you hear me
out so okay so that's interesting so
these so anyway yeah but that's just
that's the biggest one but then ya got
like traumatic brain injury and you got
and put and orthopedic stuff I mean if
you're in a vehicle that is designed to
withstand an ID going off you mean
you'll survive you survive but you did
like the the bottom of it would come up
and slam into the right item that pelvis
and the spine speaking of that I just
wear and tear on your body even if
you're not blown up so speaking of that
and this question is from so these are
veterans that have been in combat right
just yeah that turns generic veteran
right right because many most veterans
have not been in combat right so oh so
do they have more well I don't know well
yeah I mean you know we presume it's
combat well here we would have to assume
because I mean I mean I'm going to say
carpal tunnel doesn't count
I've been sitting at this desk filling
out these reports for weight my wrists
are killing me actually I have this book
called dear dear America which is a
collection of letters home from Vietnam
I was collected before they made a
Vietnam Memorial here in lower Manhattan
and so on the memorial or these are
subsets of these letters hook is all of
them at school and just to your point
Mary these are letters from all manner
of servicemen serving in Vietnam and
there's some talking about like their
friends getting blown up in front of
them and I and and wading through the
muck and mire and the mosquitoes and
then there's another letter of someone
who's in an a in an office I envy 't nam
saying i can't you know i want to laugh
but it's so hot in here it's almost 94
degrees and the fan doesn't work i did
these working conditions are under
horrible under its right give out any
[ __ ] idea what's going on around you
around you right you go ahead typewriter
keys are so i think your biggest problem
is your biggest problem that's really
what that is yeah whatever your biggest
problem is that's your biggest problem
wow that's cool i'm not coming we got
two and a half minutes how many
questions can you squeeze into this
alright you know what i go here's the
deal i'm going to we're going to go
philosophical s : house our own house
our says do you think there can be or
ever has been something that can unite
humans so effectively as war what a
profoundly mars mission
oh look at you with the Mars mission
landing a human Mars mad I need
everybody on batoon
into that right mm-hmm think mmm well so
I so I let me agree and add to that so
I've thought a lot about things that
unite humanity okay so one of them is
war which is the largest organized
unification of humans that we experience
not to mobilizes us like a good war
exactly and what add thing is it
mobilizes us against one another but
it's nonetheless mobile mobilizing
another one is the Olympics thrill and
another is the World Cup it's by the way
as a metaphor for war yes it is actually
I'm so - is the World Cup except you
don't end up dead at the end of all
right so World Cup the Olympics and the
International Space Station when you
look at the cost of the International
Space Station the number of countries
involved it is the greatest
collaboration of nations outside of the
waging of war well look at just the
total investment that has gone in it
basically three billion a year plus so
yeah yes so I agreed landing on Mars
could do that if it's done as a global
ocean as this dunnage it would be
wouldn't it I mean don't you think it
can be but I don't have enough
confidence in the human species to think
that we wouldn't do it out of
competitive urges rather than orbital
edges so you're saying that if we make
it a reality show competition between
countries we're more apt to go to Mars
than if we were just to wait for us to
finalize the gathering is that your urge
to be innovative is greater stimulated
when you're in competition than when
your cooperation that's my feeling here
okay as capitalism at its best reveals
where like what do you want I want your
money
I don't want you to give your money the
other person so now that competition
drives me to be better there it a guy
there it is at you there it is
I think we're out of time oh my god oh
my god well let me just this but so so
so Mary let me let me let me break ranks
here and pull away from chucks questions
okay is it one other thing you want us
to know about your book before we before
we end and start off today oh it's it's
a it's a it's a dark topic but it's an
interesting quirk e fun we I don't want
people to get I mean it's assuming more
serious but
they're the people in the military have
a good sense of humor and it you have to
I said yeah
anytime there's death involved in life
and death and all that so it's so it's
um it's fun it said you interviewed you
interviewed servicemen I was I was on a
nuclear sub I was in Camp lemon let you
in took me a year and a half to get on
guide oh I know yeah that's pretty cool
that's cool yeah that's cool so so I'm
all over the place and it's an
interesting it's a foreign culture and
like any foreign culture it's just a
really interesting place to go and to
learn about so cool Mary thanks again
for being on Startalk thank you Dan and
so we'll just I want to be on your on
your tour list every single time oh you
bet I'll never get I would be like the
only show to had everyone on that damn
books yeah we get them all for sex out
well we got to close out this part of
the show when star talk returns shut
nice and Bill Nighy take over the studio
for a segment of maker themed cosmic
queries yes what to you by Google that's
right maker theme that's a whole new
thing people getting into yeah you know
what it's kind of cool because they're
encouraging people to be makers yeah you
know to innovators inventors you know I
think we have lost some of that over the
last couple of decades yes and with nice
to bring it back and now it's
technologically it's IT based for a lot
of it absolutely yeah yeah all right
Chuck I'll look forward to that segment
I'm out of here we'll see you guys next
time on Startalk
this is Startalk
you
[Music]